tout a commencé sur le forum wall street
baisse de la plate forme réduite une
communauté de boursicoteurs en ligne qui
compte tout de même plus de 5 millions
de membres
ces traders amateurs ont réussi à semer
un vent de panique à la bourse de new
york et à piéger en quelque sorte de
gros fonds d'investissement
ces derniers font ce que l'on appelle du
short sellings de la vente à découvert
en français grosso modo les short
sellers comme on les appelle achètent
des actions qu'ils espèrent voir n'ont
pas augmenté comme des investisseurs
classiques mais baissé il emprunte ainsi
des actions qu'ils ne possèdent pas les
vendent à prix fort en espérant pouvoir
les racheter une fois les prix
dégringoler et sam c'est ce que de gros
fonds d'investissement
on entendait réaliser avec gamestop une
enseigne de jeux vidéo en difficulté
financière en mars l'action gameloft ne
valait que deux dollars 57 les gros
fonds d'investissement ont donc short et
l'action c'est là que la communauté du
forum
wall street baisse est entré en jeu en
se coordonnant en ligne ces amateurs se
sont rués sur l'action gamestop
provoquant une flambée considérable du
titre le 25 janvier dernier s'il pesait
en 6 347 dollars 51 à la clôture de wall
street
conséquence un vent de panique et le
début des difficultés pour les fonds
d'investissement exemple avec melvin
capitale selon le financiel times
l'entreprise new-yorkaise aurait ainsi
perdu entre 2 75 et 3 milliards de
dollars selon les estimations
face à la tournure des événements les
autorités publiques se sont emparés de
la faire le régulateur américain des
marchés financiers le s ici a indiqué
surveiller les faits de très près et la
classe politique à gauche notamment il
voit l'histoire de l'arroseur arrosé
pendant des années ces mêmes fonds
spéculatifs et investisseurs fortunés
consterné aujourd'hui par les
transactions sur gamestop ont traité le
marché boursier comme leur propre casino
alors que tout le monde en paye le prix
il est grand temps pour la scc et les
autres régulateurs financiers de se
réveiller de faire leur travail et avec
une nouvelle administration et des
démocrates qui dirige le congrès j'ai
l'intention de m'assurer qu'ils le
feront
c'est vraiment quelque chose de voir des
gens de wall street qui ont longtemps
traité notre économie comme un casino
se plaindre d'un forum qui traite
également le marché comme un casino
nombreux sont ceux aussi à faire le
parallèle avec le mouvement de 2009
occupy wall street qui entendait faire
plier la finance dans un sens c'est dû
occuper wall street version 2.0 plutôt
que depuis le parc zuccotti après
gamestop les membres du forum wall
street bête semble avoir d'autres cibles
ces derniers jours ils se seraient déjà
intéressés aux actions de la chaîne de
cinémas et m6 ou encore à celle du
fabricant de téléphones blackberry une
lettre ouverte a aussi été adressée à la
chaîne cnbc si dans laquelle ses traders
amateurs déclare la guerre aux géants de
la finance
j'espère qu'ils vont souffrir nous
voulons voir des pertes en cascades
ont-ils ainsi écrit